Can and how can I use a tens unit to alleviate foot and hand or opportunity?
Absolutely.
A very pro tens unit.
You can use a tens unit on a lot of things.
I mean tens unit is going to mainly affect muscles.
But it's going to affect the nerves too.
You don't certainly want to put a tens unit over a cancer.
So use some common sense about that.
You're using a tens unit on your legs.
Absolutely.
Great thing.
Great thing to do.
Tens units are great.
They're cheap.
They're really.
Everybody should have a tens unit.
Since I don't have access to oxygen chambers, are there other options?
I've also heard some people would put a soaked towel of hydrogen peroxide over the location of the cancer to provide oxygen.
Is there benefit in doing this?
I've heard that too.
I cannot.
For the life of me.
Imagine the physiological process that would actually release oxygen into the in through the skin into the tissue.
So no, there can be danger in hydrogen peroxide to you have to be careful.
Hydro peroxide is an oxidative agent in itself.
Just that.
So the mission over.
I'm pretty sure of a video of this.
The difference between an oxidizing agent and oxygen.
So an oxidizing agent is a molecule of oxygen that's a free radical.
So those are those are reactive.
Those are called also reactive oxygen species.
They damage your cell membranes.
And they can cause cancer.
So reactive oxygen species.
Other free radicals are basically dangerous because they can cause damage.
And so if you so the idea was, okay, well, hyzer peroxide, that's that's going to be good because that's going to kill cancer because it releases oxygen.
It releases an oxygen ion.
And that can be damaging.
So ions are are are unstable molecules that want to attach to something and they if they attach to a cell membrane or they attach to.
They can be good because if they attach to a bacteria, they could help kill a bacteria.
Hydro peroxide on a wood is actually good because it liberates a free radical of 0 to minus.
And then it will attach to bacteria virus is the wounded will kill the bacteria virus.
That's a good thing.
So it actually works real well as a typical and a septic because it forms free radicals.
So hydro peroxide is H2O2 and it tends to give off oxygen free radical and then convert to H2O.
So you don't want those oxygen free radicals in your body.
So people that consume hydro peroxide thinking that it's going to be good for them because I'm going to consume it.
It's going to kill things in my body.
There's danger to that. Yes, it could kill bacteria in your stomach could kill bacteria in your.
The testicle track, but if you have those oxygen free radicals, they cause damage.
Further, they cause proxy nitrate.
So they bind together and they cause what's called proxy nitrate that it's a very strong.
For your radical and a very strong cancer causing agent, you actually have systems in your body through your SOD panelists pathways that help break that down and get rid of that.
So you're not increasing 0 to oxygen in your tissue by use of hydrogen peroxide.
I'll guarantee you that that's just wrong biochemistry whoever came up with these some of these ideas.
It's just it's not correct physiology or biochemistry. So I would say no to that.